[Music]
well hello everybody
sorry for the delay we've been having
some audio
troubles and technical difficulties but
here we are
it's nice and warm in this studio you
guys are tuning in for
logo therapy logo therapy uh jonah thank
you very much
okay today's episode we're gonna be
talking about two designers
doing two logos i got that mixed up and
it's today
today so it's going to be angeline and
miha jovan say hello to the people
hello hello good morning from manila
maganda
[Applause]
work he is a calligrapher extraordinaire
and
he's back as our returning champion as
well as mihai mihai say hello to the
people
this is gonna be a really fun show this
is some of mihai's work you guys i'll be
slipping in out of character
i don't know what i'm doing here i'm
doing peter pa or something like that
so let's get right into we don't want to
waste any more of your time you guys
up first is the designer i think i got
this right
mariana pereira i know i butchered that
i'm so sorry
and this is your logo it's for tea
journeys
javen what you got for us cool so
starting out with cheese journeys um the
reason why i chose this logo
is because um i really like the feel of
it
and it kind of feels like it's
hand-drawn and
if you see like the the works downstairs
she actually
made a couple of applications already i
mean this is actually this is an actual
product
oh wow so yeah and
it's actually a pretty good logo but i
think that we can improve improve it
further
yeah so let's try to deconstruct the
photo uh the logo for a bit
okay um so yeah um
i tried to put some bounding boxes and
the baseline and the cap height for the
type so
if we try to look at things further uh
you can see that
the baseline and the cap heights are
kind of
it's kind of in an odd shape considering
like this layer t here and it bows up
towards the center left
yeah yeah center left and if we
look at it further it's actually um
a like mathematically it's not optically
arranged because if you look at the
letter t on the left left side
there's a ton of volume here in the
lower left part
and this is actually one of the things i
wanted to point out is the layout so
one thing to remedy this is to actually
just move the logo
a bit to the right and
with the next iteration like it's off
center but
if you look at the overall um
volume on the left and the right it
actually um
it's kind of equal yes you're talking
about
optically balanced and not versus versus
mathematical
and so we have to account for the space
the open counter underneath
the crossbar of the t so we want to
shift
the paper boat or hat whatever that is
to the right
yeah yeah excellent work cool
oh you thought it was a you thought this
was a paper hat okay i don't know is
that a boat or a hat or something i
don't
know
it's a boat yeah it's about okay yeah i
don't know anything about the project
cool um oh yeah the product is about t
by the way um it's a tea originated from
china
so i skipped a brief for a bit so yeah
okay it's a cheap product yeah
um so yeah moving on uh so
that's one of the things that i want to
change uh the next one is a scale
so i just went ahead and whipped up the
golden ratio just to scale things up a
bit
so that it it just has a reference for
it
and the old golden ratio
you guys i just want to give you a word
of warning just because you use the
golden ratio does not mean
you're golden it's just a guideline for
proportions okay
yeah and um if
if we go to the next page actually i
didn't really follow the ratio it's
it's more of me the skill both of the
elements here
so yeah um this is kind of like the
after
uh you can see that a week there's room
for us to breathe when we're looking at
the logo it's not very cramped like the
one a while ago there's
space between the element and the type
yeah
and one more thing that i want to modify
a bit is the
the type itself like if you can see like
the volume the kerning between the j
and the o uh this part
it's kind of tight compared to the
spacing here
and yeah so
yeah one of the things that i want to
change is actually the
spacing kerning so not too
not too wide just enough for the letters
to breathe
especially all of these are in caps so
you might you might have some feedback
with the way that i'm trying to space
the
letters but yeah this is in general how
i see things
um for example this can
go a little bit tighter just because the
of just because of how this [ __ ] uh how
this pairing
shapes up so yeah um like moving on
so this is like the before and after you
can see there uh
even the slight slightest change like
gives a
a ton of impact the the one with the
brown
is the before and the after is the
actual work so yeah
um so moving on like this is like the
before and after
that this is like the yeah so on this
attempt or this kind of critique or
modification i see that you're making
very small adjustments this time around
instead of just redesigning the whole
thing right oh that's the next phase
oh okay this is this is the phase all
right let's get on with it then keep
going
so um like
my the thing that i want to point out
here is that even with just
a little uh even with just subtle
changes there's
um there's a ton of difference that you
can see like the scaling
like it i i i think that the one after
breeds more even if we're just like
manipulating the negative space so yeah
this is like a couple of changes yeah
okay and
before we move on here to me the letter
spacing between the t and the e still to
feel way too close relative to
a yeah right so i would adjust that to
the left and
i like you moving the paper boat up
north but i think it's too big
it just feels like now it's dominating i
like the smaller size better it's just
maybe there's a combination where it's
smaller but higher up so that it gives
you that breathing space
okay yes that's all i'm going to say you
don't have to do it so i'm just saying
repeat that so yeah um
like moving on like one of the major
things that i saw is the combination of
the
mark itself and the type so if you can
look at the type closer it's actually
pretty rough kind of looks like it's
something that's hand drawn
yeah but if you look at the mark it's
pretty clean oh okay yes
you need to rough it up yes so it's
something that i
kind of sketch on my uh kind of did some
sketching on the side
so moving on to like the second phase
like it's gonna skip through there's
another problem with it too
the back side of the paper boat there's
a very thin
narrow white shape so when you zoom out
you can't even see it so i would
probably advise to work on that as well
yeah yeah mm-hmm either add something
uh it's one of the things that i tried
to solve but
yeah um so yeah let's start with the
type first okay so
uh since this cut uh this um
the logo is going to a more very
hand-drawn field
i kind of went ahead and did some
sketches for the type
so just a couple of sketches to just to
keep
the vibes going so these are some of the
uh usually when i uh usually when i
draft for
type it's um it's usually in model line
just to see the layout and then i try to
um supply the style after so yeah
out of all of these layouts i chose the
this one
just for kicks yeah and um
normally what i would do is to draw each
and every letter
but for the sake of demonstration i'm
gonna hack my way through this
and use something as a base font
yeah so what typeface is this this
is windsor wind elongated
windsor windsor okay it's from mona type
monotype i think
yeah um so yeah um
the thing i'm going to do is to modify
just the t and the j
but um normally what i would do is
yeah i would go through each and every
letter and redraw these things
yeah okay so how do we go from
this baseline uh this uh this type of
straight bass line to
something like this envelope distort uh
yeah a little distortion so what we're
going to do is use the warp tool for a
bit
[Music]
where uh warp tool is in effects
and in warp so to go to the shape that i
chose it
it's actually flag yeah
uh right you can actually see in the
options it's already set because i set
this a while ago
and go pretty drastic with it or you can
just go with the
pretty standard 20 just for the effect
yeah so you can as we can see like the
the type is already
warped and my natural instinct is to
actually redraw each letter because um
normally we
wouldn't use like warp text
and uh it's something that i learned
from nils's
course that if you try to manipulate
your letters you have to redraw it just
to
make things more consistent i didn't
know you took nils course
uh i i got the class cool yeah
so yeah um
one one thing that i kind of encountered
was when i
was modifying this is when i use the
outline tool
like the the path is still the same with
the one that's not unwarped
so one trick that i kind of discovered
is
um instead of using the outline tool for
text
it's to actually use the expand
appearance
so what happens is um instead of
the original text being just outlined it
actually applies the
uh the change of the change after
warping
yeah you didn't explain that too
smoothly but i got it
basically illustrator preserves the
non-destructive type
until you do expand appearance once you
do that you cannot edit the original
ones and
apply the same envelope or warp or flag
distort to it anymore right
yes all right thanks for the explanation
yeah sure
cool so like i mentioned a while ago
that i'm going to modify the t
and the j just for
because um if i
just enlarge this it's going to look
pretty weird
at least in my eye and unless unless the
the typeface has um has a
small caps font i would use that but in
this case it doesn't
right so i went ahead and like scan
uh like printed it out and drew um
[Music]
drew some some variations for this
uh this is what i normally do and as
much as possible i try to preserve the
style of the
text but this is just one of those
examples
so just where
let me try to see you in photoshop now
yeah this is an illustrator
this is still an illustrator yeah this
is just a scanned
um scan work that i have so yeah
um okay so
i'm just gonna do the expanded
pre-install
so one hack that i kind of did is
to actually just preserve like this top
part the surf
uh this airfare up top
and moved it up a little bit
just to keep the style and at the same
time
this uh the lower part of the tee
uh just drag it down while holding shift
and then i'll i would trace all of these
uh i would trace the swash here like
uh changing the the bar to the swatch
and
enlarge the this lower part here
so i'm going to show the um the output
later
if we can just go and even go next to
the
the boat yeah
okay so moving on to the boat i'm not a
very visual person so i have to take
like uh references whenever i do logos
so
in this case i had to like do a paper
boat myself and outline
the stuff uh outline the the actual logo
into something like this yeah
uh so comparing this uh
this view of the paper boat compared to
the one a while ago
um i kind of wanted this to be more
dynamic and
i wanted it to have depth that's why i
outlined the paper built in
yeah utility yes and i just added the
the tag just to be faithful to the
original logo
uh-huh yeah and now i totally get the
concept of the original drawing keep
working dude
okay because a tea bag has a rectangular
shape
and yeah and it has a little piece a
string and a tag so that
it doesn't fall in your cup and you pull
it out kind of thing so it's it's
interesting where the original shape and
form comes from
yes yes excuse me
so like moving on this is uh
i just scanned the work and
uh traced over it so it kind of looks
something like this
from this scan work it i trace it into
something like this so i just use the
trusty pen tool
we love it neo trusty pendulum it's very
nice
the pen tool yeah
just go through the lines and everything
yes and
just uh the next step is for me to
actually
um outline this outline the
the paths again so expand the stroke
yeah expand the stroke
so sound lines true yeah and for me to
combine everything just go to pathfinder
and just use the
unite one yes so
um a little trick that i did for the
next step is to actually use the
roughing tool
uh what i wanted to do was to preserve
the
um the kind of hand-drawn feel that the
original logo is trying to exude so this
is a little bit tricky
because it can go pretty haywire so
the tool that i'm using is roughing tool
so if you go to effects
go down to distort and transfer
transform and choose the roughing tool
yeah um if you can see the preview it's
gonna go haywire
because it's gonna you have to change
the values to
absolute so when you say relative it's
actually relative to
the percentage and the how the element
is
so if you use absolute it's just gonna
it's just gonna use the pixels
so i'm just gonna use 1px i don't want
it that rough
yeah and i'm going to change the
instead of corners i'm going to go with
the smooth
setting it's not going to be that sharp
and yeah i think one or two pixels is
pretty okay
a little subtle thing not not to overdo
it right
yes yeah pretty slow i think that's a
nice trick
yes and uh let me just redo it i think
one pixel is enough
yeah yeah it's very just very subtle
okay yep so
um it's uh like the one a while ago
um as you can see when i warped this
thing
uh the the the paths
uh still what do you call this it's
still preserved yeah
so still editable yeah so we use the
same technique which
is to expand the appearance again
yeah yeah just to keep the settings yeah
okay so this is pretty much it for the
logo
and for the mark at least and
it's time for me to like combine both of
them
so this is one of the this is like the
after of the type
let me just close the pilot yeah the
after of the type and
like the after of the the mark
so it's just a matter of playing things
out and
like again i'm just trying to use the
ratio as a skill and
the final product is something like this
so i did my best to
be at faithful with the original logo
and
i i want i really wanted to exclude this
kind of hand-drawn feel if i had more
time i would have definitely
drawn i would have definitely drawn each
and every letter and
break on the mark itself so
yeah here's the before and after and i
would definitely love some feedback
if you have any okay i'm gonna give you
a little bit of a
critique here jelvin uh okay in my
normal voice here
people were like what what's going on
with chris
okay i have some issues with this logo
let's
let's not cut to my face i want to look
at the whole thing yeah there we go okay
i have a lot of problems with this right
now and i appreciate the whole
journey that you took us on on this a
tea adventure
but the thing is i don't find that
there's a lot of cohesion between
the word mark and the symbol i like all
the changes you've made but then i feel
like
these are from two different universes
whereas in the original
it was more of a monostroke typeface
so that i can see that there's a a
single stroke monostroke
iconic drawing i want to see those come
together i know you're very good at
doing those kinds of monostroke logos as
well
and i want to see those tied together
let's zoom in a little tighter to your
tee journeys your version javen
yeah yeah thank you uh we want to be
very careful when we're doing the
crossbar the horizontal strokes they
need to be vertically
thinner mathematically than they are
vertically
right yes because they re so now you can
see the crossbar of the t
it feels a little heavy it feels like
it's unbalanced it's going to tip over
and i don't know that you've modified
the j so you pulled it up and you
created the i don't know what that's
called the leg or the arm of the j
to dip way below the baseline what's it
called
the center is that a descender
whatever that is the hook part of the j
you dropped it down
so it really ties in together this is
like an old-school way of
treating lettering and typography where
you do a large initial cap letter
but gelvin is absolutely right you can't
just scale it up because then the stroke
weights are inconsistent and it looks
like you just scaled it up
so then it's important to draw i got
some valuable tips from watching you
work and that
you'll actually start with a typeface so
you don't have to do everything from
scratch and then you'll just
print it out and draw over so that
you're not wasting your time and energy
doing all that stuff
there's still some inconsistencies in
here like it looks like t
e a and journeys so i think we need to
work on our letter spacing there where
optically it's feeling a little off to
me
okay and maybe you give the space under
the crossbar of the tee
a little bit more room to to breathe a
little bit
you know because yeah that's that's
already feeling a little bit better
and maybe just for for fun can you
modify the crossbar the t so it's not
thicker than the vertical stroke
give me a couple yeah yeah just let's
just bring that down a little bit
well just yeah something like that yeah
yeah so let's zoom back out okay um
we got to work on that a little bit
because the ends don't want to be
thicker than the crossbar itself
so the left part of the tee that curl
that that's a little bit heavy okay i
think that's good so let's step back
and let me do this you guys at this
point in the game at this point in the
show
wait let's let's uh look at both both
logos
okay all right so you guys
let us know what do you think did jelvin
improve it did you learn some tips which
version do you prefer the original or
the new version
okay and let us know in the comments go
ahead and
say original or new version in the
comments
below right now okay thank you very much
jalvin
uh i would hit the plus button but i'm
too busy doing stupid there it is
good job
[Applause]
but i'm too busy doing stupid voices
okay okay let me go back to my my deck
here
and okay up up next
is alexander pongo and his logo is
travin
treven travin this is a pretty nice logo
i have to say it's very balanced
so i'm crazy curious as to what mihai is
going to do with this so mihai
it is now your turn give us one
second gentlemen can you stop sharing
screen java your breaking protocol
stop hogging all the screen time if we
get you to share me hi
it's all good there we are give us one
more
second we are almost back ladies and
gentlemen
awesome possum people are confused about
what voice you're impersonating here
hey what if i just make it my own voice
peter pan if pewdiepie had a child
with zimri i guess that's what i would
sound like i just actually don't know
either their voices that well
just this is both a little goofy and fun
because we're gonna have a little fun
apparently people on the internet want
fun voices while they're learning
so tell us if it's helpful to you or you
prefer the
straight robotic chris
cool so we got all right ready to roll
okay so hi everyone i'm glad to be back
and i would like to congratulate jelvin
on the
improvement of the logo very nice job
wow so gorgeous
yeah my logo for today is
from alexander fongo he's a graphic
designer from
ukraine and uh his logo is called
the treven it's for uh travel up and the
main idea behind the logo is you know
we made up over the anchor and
the pin oh nice yeah so it's
pretty pretty simple uh the only
issue maybe that i have with the local
maybe
it's a bit too too minimal in my
in my opinion and that's what alexander
said and he would
envision the logo you know by being a
bit more
modern you know for for an app so i will
try to do that and
at the end we can all decide if it's you
know if it's better before or
after so um i initially started to
like always like i always do you know by
doing some uh sketches
uh you can hopefully you can you can see
well
so i and um i tried to
initially i tried to only to improve the
idea that alexander had you know with
the pin
and the location mark and here's my
what i did in the beginning i um
i played around with this idea a lot
and but um then i realized it's
it's not not going in the right
direction something you know felt
not felt
not good just to say it and then
i went back to my sketching uh book
and as i was drawing the logo and if you
can see here
i have the anchor can you see yes
yeah i have the anchor and then
as i was drawing it i kind of envisioned
you know introducing
the letter t and making it part of the
the anchor so here's here's the
more solid version if i may made with
thick lines this is just a rough sketch
and here's the actual process that went
in behind the logo this
is the final logo actually this is not
final look almost the final logo
and here just like last time i made a
breakdown of my process and the steps
that i took to to create the
actual logo and to and to get here
okay before you move on i like seeing
this process this evolution
and it's it's almost like you're like a
robot
you do one thing you try another thing
and then you keep advancing equally
spaced apart and i love seeing that
because you can see sometimes it's
deceptive when somebody shows you an
original mark
or the finished mark i should say not
the original the finished mark you think
wow yeah of course you just do it like
that
but breaking it down like this makes it
seem so attainable
right and the whole point of what we're
doing here at the future in the future
academy which is where you guys are
watching this live stream from
is to try to help to increase the
conversation on design design
process and show you how other people
think through a problem this isn't a
beauty contest this
is not to say one is better than the
other because then we've lost the point
which is here to try to show you options
and
educate you and hopefully get you guys
skill level up
all right keep going man good job it's
about it's about uh learning and
yeah the main idea behind this uh
breakdown is to show you know
as simply as possible how to how do you
achieve a simple mark because
at the end of the day you know logo
should be simple and it
should be i mean the creation
process is pretty you know sometimes
complicated but
you should achieve it in a very simple
way
so kind of the first step that i did is
i just took you know the circle i'm
gonna take this
this circle circle so it's
just um a stroke yeah stroke with uh
let's say 30 pixel width
and then um next step that i did was
you know just to create an l shaped path
again with the pen tool i'm just take
this one but
i'm going to show how how do you
continue it so
just take the pencil and draw holding on
shift
yeah yeah holding shift just to make
sure
your lines are straight yep and then i
drop it
yes press what uh i on the keyboard and
i for i dropped yeah so
um i'm just going to take this this one
this path right here and make sure it's
uh
i'll switch to outline mode just to make
sure it's uh
intercept centered yeah yeah and
next step was to was to
round the corners of the
l-shaped path so kind of like so
we need to make sure we have this uh
straight
small line here right i'll explain why
in a bit uh so
the next step i'm just going to take the
the hook that i drew you can actually
obtain this
hook you know by by creating an
uh circle so just by pressing
l on from the keyboard and holding alt
and shift
you can get a circle and then you can
you have to just play around with the
angle but
this is for the illustrator cc i think
only
not for the older versions
so i'm just going to take my hook that i
have already made
and just make sure it aligns with the
with our uh
graph here you still have not outlined
that path yet right you have not
expanded that
yeah yes this is one of the next steps
okay so i need to move this uh
hook uh down a bit so
so it's i think it's 14 pixels one two
three four
um okay so next step would be to
expand what you just told you know
the f or path and to remove
the unwanted parts right here so we get
them
smooth you know transition between the
hook and the
round part is going to object
expand and okay
and i'll just select both of my
parts and hit shift
m on the keyboard
and just get rid of this part right here
oh yeah
something like this nice and the next
step is
what you talked about you know uh for
children
uh i don't know maybe is it just me but
when i look at this
um around it area right here i kind of
get the impression that
you know it's thicker than than
that's good so so i have showed here uh
yeah this is the the blue one is the
adjusted
version and the the scion in the back is
the
original one so i'm gonna do the same
for for our
example so i'll just select these points
that i need these four points and go
down
i'm doing just just to just so people
know and doing this
um by uh judging visually yeah optically
yeah yeah so i i found out that
the best way is to go go down at three
or four pixel so it's one two
three four and in my opinion
it it looks a bit it's it's a very small
change
but it does a lot for the optical
balance of the logo
and then the next step would be to take
these two points
and then go go to the right
to the right yeah yeah two
so two pixels and then again
and then again for these two yep so i
kinda
have a more balanced logo yeah
the next step would be to i have to
unite these two paths right here
just select them and from the pathfinder
menu
window pathfinder uh
unite now
next step would be to
reflect our the right part of the
hook so right click transform reflect
or you can use the reflect tool the one
from
with oh i i usually go with this
doesn't matter um just and now just make
sure
the our uh
they align online yeah i have to do this
manually um
get out of outline mode and one of the
last steps would be to
to add this uh action the white space
yes the offset path easiest way the
easiest way you can do this is by
selecting your uh this path right here
go to
object path
i missed it offset path and i already
have my value here it's
um i used 17 pixels because
if you go if you go lower it
will not be visible at small sizes right
if you go
any bigger it will create you know uh
it will draw too much attention so i
found out that
before you click that button never mind
yeah oh no i was going to say it because
i was just going to say you guys click
on the preview so you can kind of gauge
the size
the the numerical values that mihae is
giving you is relative to the size of
his artwork so each person
you're going to need to make your own
adjustments based on how you look at
this okay so he just knows because he's
done this
before yeah okay well just just to
give a small idea you don't want to
make the offset path you know cross b
this circle
so kind of a reference a small reference
okay but yeah
it depends on your uh size of your
canvas
so next step would be to just cut off
minus the front
of yes exclude it doesn't matter
any of this and just delete the there
you go
yeah and the next
step and final actually is
i'll just place it here on me on my
guides and as we can see it's not
perfectly aligned and i'll just take my
the cross
stroke i hope i got fight
right actually googled i don't know is
it called crosstalk it's called the
cross stroke
you're correct okay and
yeah this is the this is the
result and below i did
some uh small mock-ups you know by
placing it in
into a actual uh
what you call it i usually do
uh this for my clients just to show
them how the logo works you know uh
together with
similar apps so we can uh you know get a
more general view
how the logo would work uh here's some
font treatment what i did i used a very
clean
[Music]
and sans-serif typeface do you know what
typeface that is
everybody i was asked so i want to make
sure we have it right now i think it
necks are bold i'm i'm not not very sure
to be honest okay that's fine
and yeah this is uh before and after so
this is it basically great so
you've been able to create a mark it's
straying away a little bit from the
original idea of the pin drop and the
anchor
but i didn't even read the original as
an anchor myself so i just saw it as an
arrow and you've been able to create
that anchor
and you've been able to add the letter t
in there so it's a little bit more
visible so
these are two very viable
alexander did but you know it didn't
work so when things don't work out you
just have to find
another way yeah very good
okay excellent good job good job
everybody good job
[Applause]
okay i i think uh let's put those two up
on screen for a second
the critique i'm gonna have for you
right now is perhaps you just need to
scale the t down a little bit
and yeah your mark just because i just
want some breathing space
okay generally speaking if you give
things a little negative space it just
feels a little bit more elegant
okay there actually you're right just on
that
let's do this let's put the original on
the left hand side and let's put the new
one on the right so that we can then ask
our
audience who's tuning in to vote okay
okay okay let's center this up on the
screen all right guys
let us know what you think do you prefer
the original
on the left or the new version on the
right
let us know type in your comments
right now okay
yeah overall i think you did a really
good job again another thing that i
might cheat a little bit
i'm not sure is that that that the
counter the negative space inside the
loop of the
of the anchor at really small sizes
might start to disappear on you i don't
know yeah so
the thing is initially i went with a
bigger circle
but the main problem was when you looked
at it
you were drawn uh you know by the
diverse circle
initially yeah so i didn't want that i
want
you know people to look here and then
go down so the circle is just the
element of the anchor is should not uh
should not raise yeah well i think okay
a couple other things that you might
want to explore and i've seen people do
this in their marks is they'll do a
little
negative shadow underneath the circle to
kind of create some dimension
and make it feel like there's some
volume to it so it's not 2d flat
uh that's just something to think about
do you know what i'm talking about mihai
yeah
yeah yeah we don't need to do that okay
i'm just throwing out some suggestions
and things to explore for you guys
i think overwhelmingly people are saying
the new one
is the preferred one so good job good
job guys
thank you thank you yeah another thing i
want to mention here because in the chat
a lot of people
are very interested in the ideation and
brainstorm process so
mihai when you were thinking about this
i guess what other research
went into your ideation process
mostly i i would say it was my uh
my experience that played you know the
the
the most important role so
i advise everyone you know to just
let your creativity flow and
you know experiment a lot and also if
you if you
if you have some colleagues you know
designer colleagues ask for uh
their opinion and they they they'll help
don't try to do it you know everything
alone because
you will not want to do almost
everything so try to try to ask people
try to show to people
maybe post some progress on social media
and they will uh
they will help you but yeah the idea
just came you know just like any idea
very
very spontaneously and yeah i'm
i'm pretty happy how it turned out i
don't know for the audience but
yeah no they're very happy about it
here's a little thing that you guys can
do here's a little
hot tip the hot tip is this is when
you're designing
try not to judge yourself too much
because it can be paralyzing when you
design something oh that's not good
that's not refined
whatever it is so don't do that what i
would and advise you to
encourage you to do is use the sleep on
it rule
design something design as many
iterations as you want you're in the
groove
you're feeling like a creative genius
leave that alone and then with fresh
eyes the next day look at it again and
sometimes you're like wow that's really
good it still is good
after some days actually or actually you
can also go for a walk
it always helps you know uh when i work
on something and you get
you know tired from looking at the logo
and
it seems like you know desperate and you
don't have any more ideas
i just uh leave my desk and go for a 30
minute walk and
when i come back i always get something
i mean yeah
maybe i don't get the final final logo
but
i make a lot of improvements yeah
and having a little objectivity will
help you i remember going to a color
correction course and the
colorist told us that after 10 seconds
of looking at image you lose
all objectivity you start to fall in
love with it you can't tell if it's warm
or if it's cool anymore
and that's the thing so he has to look
away or switch images constantly because
you think it's great okay i want to
answer a couple of questions and then i
want to
also have you guys answer this question
from beginning to end both jelvin and
mihai
how long did it take you to do this
entire process obviously you've worked
on this so
showing us in in kind of like fake real
time
creates this illusion that these things
can be done in minutes and they can't
the first question i'm gonna ask though
is
how am i doing the music that's how i'm
doing it so
this is what cool design bro that's how
we do it that's on an ipad
okay so jelvin and mihai how long did it
take you to do your your
your process beginning to end jalvin you
can go first
okay thanks yeah so with minutes uh two
to three days give and take
like two to three hours two to three
days that's the total time
i mean it's a short how many hours dude
um probably
eight eight hours eight to ten hours so
if he says eight to ten hours it's
probably
14 hours designers classically
misrepresent how many hours things work
they worked on so it took a little time
it takes some time to work on this stuff
to explore through the ideas
and if you knew exactly what you're
gonna do it probably would not take
very long to do at all but you have to
go through this whole creative process
and then mihai how about you how long
did it take you to do this
um roughly i think it was somewhere
between six
and eight hours okay it's probably 35
hours operation and preparation
yeah it took you some time okay one
thing okay
i i think that's it are there any other
questions that we need to answer
um no more comments and they love the
work
okay everybody's super happy so i gotta
get my deck right here
all right so stop sharing my screen yeah
you can stop sharing
okay so jelvin and mihai thank you very
much again for doing this and if you're
watching this channel and you happen to
work for a manufacturer that makes
camera equipment
um microphones and things like that we
would love to have you as a sponsor so i
can send
every logo therapist a kit so that they
can improve their video
live streaming and game okay just
throwing that out there to the universe
somebody knows somebody at sony canon
logitech road sure whatever
let him know to watch his channel and
say hey we could be helping people out
and
get some free air time okay that's it
you guys if you're having a little case
of the
fear of missing out make sure you guys
follow us
on facebook it's at the future is here
and then go ahead and submit your logos
we now have three teams of logo
therapists picking through the logos
and and then doing their magic and soon
to be a fourth team
so if you guys like this episode but
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe and
hit that bell i want to send a big shout
out and a
just a little note of appreciation to
all our sustaining members thank you
very much you guys know you are you're
part of the donation
that's it for me i'm out of here guys
stay warm
we are see you guys on the next show
next show